THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: MORE THAN 20
DEMOCRATS CONTENDING TO BE THE
NEXT PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
THE DEMOCRATIC VOTERS DON'T HAVE
A LOT OF CHOICE.
THEY CAN DECIDE WHETHER THEIR
NOMINEE WILL BE THE FIRST
HISPANIC OR FEMALE PRESIDENT OR
THE FIRST GAY PRESIDENT.
ON EVERYTHING THAT MATTERS, WHAT
THEY BELIEVE, THEY ARE RUNNING
ON A PLATFORM OF OPEN BORDERS,
OPEN PRISONS AND FREE HEALTHCARE
FOR ILLEGALS AND ALL HAVE THE
SAME TONE.
ALL SPENT THE ELECTION CAMPAIGN
ASSERTING THEIR SUPERIORITY TO
THE COUNTRY.
THEY DESERVE TO BE PRESIDENT
BECAUSE THEY ARE BETTER THAN
DONALD TRUMP AND THEY ARE BETTER
THAN YOU TOO.
ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL BERNIE
SANDERS HAS BEEN DEMANDING THAT
OTHER PEOPLE AND OTHER
BUSINESSES INCREASE THEIR
MINIMUM WAGE TO $15 AN HOUR.
HE ACCUSED WAL-MART OF PLAYING
EMPPLOYEES STARVATION WAGES.
WATCH THIS.
>> I WANT TO APPLAUD THE
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
WORKERS FROM COAST TO COAST --
PEOPLE WHO WORK IN McDONALD'S
AND BURGER KING -- WHO STOOD UP
AND DEMANDED THAT THE FEDERAL
MINIMUM WAGE BE RAISEED TO A
LIVING WAGE.
$15 AN HOUR.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
BERNIE SANDERS IS SO CONFIDENT
HE IS A DEEPLY GOOD PERSON, HE
IS NOT SHACKLED TO THE SAME
RULES THAT HE WANTS EVERYONE
ELSE TO FOLLOW.
FOR EXAMPLE, RIGHT NOW, SANDERS
CAMPAIGN IS BATTLING ITS OWN
WORKERS.
THEY ARE BEING PAID THE SAME
STARVATION WAGES THAT WAL-MART
EMPLOYEES GET.
SANDERS HASN'T BUDGED.
IF THEY ARE NOT HAPPY THEY CAN
GO WORK ON ANOTHER CAMPAIGN OR
QUIT.
IF HIS PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN
DOESN'T WORK OUT, HE SHOULD
MANAGE A WAL-MART.
HE WOULD BE GOOD AT IT.
BERNARD IS NOT THE ONLY
CANDIDATE WHO CAN'T MATCH HIS
OWN RHETORIC.
KAMALA HARRIS IS ALSO RUNNING ON
A PLATFORM OF BEING MORALLY
SUPERIOR TO EVERYONE ELSE AND
PARTICULARLY TO YOU.
HER ADMINISTRATION WILL PUNISH
AMERICAN BUSINESSES FOR BEING
SEXIST.
LISTEN TO.
>> I WILL SHIFT THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO THE BIG
CORPORATIONS TO REQUIRE THEM TO
PROVE NAY ARE PAYING PEOPLE
EQUALLY FOR EQUAL WORK.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Tucker: HARRIS PROMISES WHEN
SHE IS PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AND SHE COULD BE, WHEN
THAT HAPPENS, COMPANIES WILL BE
HIT WITH BIG FINES FOR HAVING A
PAY GAP OF EVEN 1% BETWEEN MEN
AND WOMEN.
THAT RAISES THE QUESTION.
WHAT IS THE PAY STRUCTURE LIKE
IN KAMALA HARRIS'S OFFICE?
SHE PAYS WOMEN ONLY 94 CENTS FOR
EVERY DOLLAR MEN EARN.
GILLIBRAND HOPPED ON EVERY FAD
AND LED THE PUSH TO FORCE OUT
FRANKEN.
HE HAD TO LEAVE OFFICE THANKS TO
GILLIBRAND AND THERE WAS NO
PROOF HE DID ANYTHING SERIOUSLY
WRONG.
HE WAS A JERK BUT NOT A RAPIST.
GILLIBRAND LOOKED BACK AND
JUSTIFIED HERSELF.
SHE SAID SHE WAS NOT LEADING A
LYNCH MOB, JUST PROTECTING THE
WEAK.
>> HOW DO YOU EVALUATE YOUR ROLE
IN FRANKEN RESIGNING?
>> SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO DO WHAT
IS WRITE EVEN IF IT'S HARD OR
SOMEONE YOU LIKE OR LOVE.
THERE WERE 8 CREDIBLE
ALLEGATIONS.
THE LAST PERSON WAS A
CONGRESSIONAL STAFFER.
HAVING WORKED IN THIS SPACE FOR
5 YEARS, IF I CAN'T PROTECT THE
WOMEN IN MY WORK SPACE AND STAND
UP FOR WOMEN WHO ARE ABUSED OR
HARASSED IN THE WORKPLACE, I AM
NOT DOING MY JOB.
>> Tucker: THAT'S GILLIBRAND'S
POSITION.
IN REAL LIFE SHE WAS PERFECTLY
HAPPY NOT TO DO HER JOB AS SOON
AS THERE WERE NO POLITICAL
POINTS TO BE SCORED.
JUST LAST SUMMER, ONE OF
GILLIBRAND'S AIDES RESIGNED OVER
SEXUAL HARASSMENT FROM A
SUPERIOR.
THE AIDE SAID SHE COMPLAINED
ABOUT IT IN GILLIBRAND'S OFFICE,
HER CONCERNS WERE QUICKLY
DISMISSED.
JUST A GIRL COMPLAINING.
THAT'S HOW GILLIBRAND ACTUALLY
LIVES.
LOOK ON THE BRIGHT SIDE, THEY
ARE NOT THE WORST HYPOCRITES IN
THE FIELD OF CANDIDATES RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT.
THAT PRIZE GOES TO BILL DE
BLASIO THE MOST INCOMPETENT
MAYOR IN THE HISTORY OF NEW
YORK.
YOU HAVE NEVER MET A SENIOR BILL
DE BLASIO SUPPORTER IN THE WILD.
THERE ARE NOT ANY.
HE BUILT HIS CAMPAIGN ABOUT HIS
CONCERN ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT.
HE LOVES ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ'S NEW GREEN DEAL.
HE STOLE THE IDEA FOR HIS CITY
AND SAID HE WILL LEAD BY
EXAMPLE.
RIGHT UNTIL HE HOPSON INTO HIS
GAS GUZZLING SUV TO HEAD TO
ANOTHER POLITICAL EVENT.
>> WE ARE HERE IN NEW YORK CITY
TO SHOW HOW IT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
TO SHOW HOW IT MUST BE DONE.
TODAY WE ANNOUNCED THE NEW YORK
CITY NOW GREERNLD.
-- GREEN DEAL.
WE HAVE SKIN IN THE GAME.
WE WILL LEAD BY EXAMPLE.
>> [MOTOR REVVING].